so is it true that your dad Ice Cube if
anybody didn't know that um did he
surprise you with the rock one time
so hear this yeah so I'm in sixth grade
all right about 12 years old and um my
dad picks me up from school now picking
me up from school is straight Grandma
business okay this is what my grandma
does yeah this is who I'm expecting to
see word travels fast when you're in
middle school and everyone's like Shay
your Dad's here your Dad's here your
Dad's here Ice Cube's here so it is
popping right now yeah immediate my
immediate reaction is what did I do
that's what I would think yeah what did
I do so now I'm walking to the car
thinking of what I could have done to
got in trouble and also what he could
have found out that I did you know so
this is going through my head I get in
the car and we're driving he's like so
how was school oh how was it good how
was your day so we're driving and he
takes me all the way down to Venice and
when you're 12 years old the valley to
Venice is forever yeah you know so
especially when you think you're about
to get your butt yeah what is happening
and he lets me know uh yeah so we're
going to be having lunch with somebody
today I'm like all right chill who and
he says it's the rock who at 12 years
old right now is my hero okay I mean
like my hero 40.
and so we go to this restaurant we sit
down big table here comes the rock all
six foot four of him and he sits down
and I can't say a word you have to
prepare a child for when they're about
to meet their Heroes I had nothing lined
up yeah so like I'm just staring at this
man talking to my dad and my dad is
nudging me like say something and I just
I just couldn't I remember I ordered a
cheeseburger he ordered a cheeseburger
he ordered a Diet Coke I thought that
was weird but we moved past it and then
uh when he when he paid for his meal and
uh the lady came and brought his change
I took a quarter I took the Rock's
quarter you did I have it in a sandwich
bag to this day I love this memory for
you this is this should be the coin and
tummy flip for anything this should be
your special question I need the Rocks
coins
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Music]